hi I'm Izzy I've never been good in
matters of the heart never had that
moment you know where everything falls
into the perfect spot who knows maybe
this will be the year you'll say that
it's all right sister I thought you were
just here for a fashion
[Music]
I'm thinking about finally you could
come with me so this is the I'm going
back to Hollywood to become a big star
like my sister thinks I can send you
those fruit bouquet things but the
pineapple on a stick by an apple I still
think we can work this out I think it's
over you can never trust a guy who has
20 of the same shirt the same color your
post-breakup your pre real world for
yourself
normal any hell you get try the whole
life having fun in your 20s a move I bet
you get a lot of girls on their backs
every day I'll work on that one
somewhere guess I'm just wondering how
you ever meet the right person I think
you just walk right into your life oh
wow I don't command you to pay attention
as I supposed to pound I'm doing a scene
with a really hot new guy from class
when I said there are other fishies in
the cement like look through the sea not
immediately at the first person that
shows up did you learn that your
sensitivity training course Sabrina
there's nothing accidental about
anything here my big sister I just want
to move on and feel better [ __ ] need
[ __ ] he kept asking me to tell him
how big his penis
oh that's everything to a guy you just
got a lie
[Music]
you